à samsung samsung samsung comment vous
allez tout se passe bien aujourd'hui
j'espère vous allez viens on va
aujourd'hui se parler du nouveau
smartphone de samsung samsung vient de
lancer ses nouveaux smartphones dans le
milieu de gamme alors vous n'êtes pas
sans savoir que samsung a plusieurs
gammes c'est comme ça chez tous les
fabricants et chez samsung vous avez
notamment la gamme est ce qu est la
gamme photo vidéo je vous ai déjà
présenté avec les fameux galaxy s 21
vous avez la gamme à la gamme acquis et
la gamme la plus large je pense qu'ils
s'adressent aux plus de personnes
possible c'est la gamme entrée milieu
bien il ya deux modèles très fort que
samsung vient justement de renouveler
qui est le gamme à 50 51 52 et le
samsung galaxy à 70 71 72
aujourd'hui on va se parler
effectivement de ces galaxies à 52 et à
72 ce qui a fait la force et la
subdivision que vous avez vous avez un
samsung galaxy à 52 4 g vous avez un
samsung galaxy à 52,5 j'ai vraiment une
division entre ces deux modèles là on va
s'adresser à deux types de personnes
différentes et vous avez le gac sia soit
112 qui est lui par contre uniquement 4
juillet pas de singer si les dictons que
de la 4g
[Musique]
alors moi ça n'interpelle déjà quand on
commence comme ça c'est de comprendre
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a de la kadji de
la saint léger d'un côté sur un modèle à
50 2 puisque on se dirait qu'on peut
avoir un seul et même modèle le modèle
que vous allez retrouver au niveau des
opérateurs sur l'a52 ça va être le
modèle à 5 g parce que poussent des
offres 5g et que la 5g veulent vraiment
que les gens qui adhèrent massivement
donc bien évidemment eux vont pousser la
5g tandis que dans le commerce
collatéral retail fnac darty boulanger
et compagnie et bien eu ce qu'ils
veulent c'est un super rapport qualité
prix
pas forcément de la saint jacques il en
coûtait plus cher ils veulent un
smartphone 4g c'est la raison pour
laquelle vous avez vraiment ces deux
modèles qui coexistent et sans vent
parle également des sites quelques
secondes puisque je vais interviewer
williams que chef de produit chez
samsung qui nous expliquera la
différence entre ces modèles
la différence de prix je voulais donner
tout de suite à 52 5 g coûte pas d'un
roulement de tambour 449 euros contre à
52 4 g qui coûte 3 179 euros dont
l'action veut à 52 avec toutes les specs
qu'il avait emballé plutôt d'un modèle
4g / veut le meilleur prix mais si on
veut se projeter déjà dans la 5g parce
que la 5g vous intéresse et bien il faut
rajouter un peu d'argent à 449 euros et
le à 72 coûte 479 euros dont pour 20
euros de plus vous avez lu à 72 ne vous
avez de la case il n'est pas là 5 j'ai
bien compris un peu l'histoire c'est
aujourd'hui une vidéo qui a réalisé en
partenariat avec rideau shield parce que
oui y avoir un nouveau smartphone
samsung galaxy à 52 ou alors à 72 c'est
super mais ne pas le protéger
c'est pas bien c'est même relativement
très très mal et chérie nous s'il vous
en avez pour tout le monde dans tous les
univers aussi bien de la crh garde tout
fait pour m sans votre samsung galaxy à
52 ou sur votre samsung galaxy à 72 et
bien d'ailleurs sur d'autres produits de
samsung ou d'autres marques pourquoi pas
vous avez donc des jolies crashgate vont
venir vous les protégez effet carbone
effet un peu plus standard poor
l'un ou pour l'autre modèle ça ça marche
super bien que vous avez plein d'univers
différents et ça j'aime beaucoup ça
vraiment sympa il ya dans l'univers des
mangas avec un notamment fairy tail je
trouve super sympa c'est vraiment très
très joli ça c'est vraiment chouette y
en a vraiment pour tous les goûts il y
en a pour tout le monde et oui mais
l'intéressé n'a pour tout le monde va
même avoir du hunter ou tard on va même
pouvoir avoir du chicago bulls
on va voir aussi du fort tu n'as qu'un
des coques approuvé par la nasa et puis
si vous voulez pas voir ado tous fermé
comme ça vous voulez voir le taux de vos
smartphones et bien vous pouvez vous
avez des crasses gars vous avez des mots
des knicks c'est pour venir customiser
aussi et changer la couleur de votre
borne c'est aussi très très très sympa
et puis bien évidemment pouvait mettre
au dos des bacs plett les backplate
elles sont aussi très cool avec
différents motifs comme ça vous allez
avoir un smartphone qui est différent
des autres dans l'univers de league of
legends pourquoi pas ça c'est aussi
super chouette et puis je pense
évidemment à venir protéger aussi
l'écran de votre smartphone grâce aux
impacts screen protector dont vous avez
un choix qui est très large chez
rhinochill je vous ai mis un code en bas
un code promo cliquer sur le lien et lé
protéger votre smartphone dans les
meilleures conditions et ça c'est
vachement bien
on est avec william comment vas tu ben
écoute ça va très bien tu es chef de
produire ici chez samsung représente la
nouvelle gamme à tout à fait qu'on a
déjà entendu ya pas très longtemps pour
parler effectivement des samsung galaxy
s 21
c'est ça l'anglais sur une autre gamme
on est plutôt sur le milieu de gamme
chez samsung ce gamin là on est sur le
moins de 500 euros
aujourd'hui en tout cas on parle de
trois nouveaux modèles en réalité deux
modèles à 52 à 52 5 g et l'a72 tu peux
m'expliquer un petit peu ce qu'ils vont
nous raconter ses smartphones l'idée
c'est de proposer des smartphones ils
sont très polyvalents et qui sont
excellents pour un prix inférieur à 500
euros
on sait aujourd'hui que voilà il ya
certaines personnes qui se tournent vers
le galaxy s mais d'autres qui préfèrent
aussi nos galaxia puisque
ils sont peut-être un peu moins cher et
embarque pour autant une grande partie
notre savoir-faire et l'idée c'est que
ces produits là pardon de proposer un
super rapport qualité prix notamment à
queue à 52 5 g qui vient proposer de la
5g et une fiche technique hyper musclé
sous les 500 euros c'est un peu le faire
de long seulement 52,5 j au fait si je
comprends bien c'est exactement ça on a
commencé sur les galaxia depuis janvier
à sortir plusieurs produits
le galaxy à 12 le galaxy à 0,2 s les
galaxies à 32 mais c'est le galaxy ya
cinq ans de 5 g qui va être la star on
va dire de ce milieu de gamme chez nous
et sur lequel on va communiquer le gros
focus qui est fait par samsung là dessus
c'est l'écran ça va être l'autonomie et
ça va être également la photo
l'autonomie parce que sur les segments
entrée et milieu de gamme c'est vraiment
ce qu'on met en avant ici pas de
recharge sans fil puisqu'on a des deux
en plastique avec différentes couleurs
personnellement j'aime bien le côté bleu
qui est assez sympa qui peut-être mon
préféré il ya le lavandou c'est pourquoi
pas assez sympa le noir et le blanc je
pense que le noir ces modèles qui se
vendra le mieux vous avez exactement ces
quatre couleurs sur l'a72 élevé à 50,2
d'ailleurs dit moi vous un commentaire
quel modèle vous préférez quelle couleur
vous préférez est-ce que c'est déjà le
bleu comme moi le lavande le noir le
blanc alors moi je suis consommateur
je vois qu'il ya de nouveaux modèles qui
peuvent m'intéresser notamment le 72
élèves à 52 bon on considérera pas
forcément la 5g parce que le 72 n'a pas
la 5g
quelle va être la grosse différence
entre ces deux smartphones sur le à 5,72
que vous avez en plus par rapport aux 52
c'est un écran qui est plus grand ok
donc c'est vraiment pour ceux qui
souhaitent se tourner vers les grands
écrans et je suis pas 6 7 6 le 12 5
c'est ça c'est ça et ceux qui souhaitent
un zoom optique x 3 sur sa partie photo
sur la 112 d'accord pour ceux qui ne
sont pas intéressés par par ses
caractéristiques la foncé sur l'a50 de
5g parce que c'est un super produit qui
est un tout petit peu moins cher que
l'eau 72 mais qui embarque la 5g et qui
embarque tout un tas de caractéristiques
hyper chouette comme la résistance à
l'eau comme un écran sans verte comme un
quadruple capteur photo comme notre
interface soignée donc vraiment aller
vers le produit
qu'on préfère eloi 52 5 g en tout cas
c'est celui qui est à la 5g pour toutes
ces caractéristiques que vous avez
évoqué votre écran est protégé avec un
verre corning gorilla glass 5
il ya une différence au niveau du taux
de rafraîchissement et ça c'est
intéressant sur lui à 52 5 g vous avez
un taux de rafraîchissement de 120 hertz
tandis que sur le à 72,4 j'ai bien
évidemment et le à 52,4 j'ai également
vous avez un taux de rafraîchissement de
90 ans donc si vous voulez aller plus
loin en termes d'expérience notamment
pour le gaming pourriez plus de fluidité
et bien il faudra aller sur le à 52 5 g
est à noter qu'ici vous avez un taux de
rafraîchissement qui est une ode
adaptatifs à la différence des samsung
galaxy s 21 qui entourent
rafraîchissement adaptatif alors si vous
n'êtes pas coutume et du terme adaptatif
et le delta et donne adaptatif c'est
très simple je vous le résumé quand vous
avez un taux de rafraîchissement de 120
hertz sur le à 52 5 g eh bien vous ne
saurez corse en hertz vous ne pourrez
pas switcher sur du 90 hier sur du 60
hertz l'adaptative permet d'adapter le
taux de rafraîchissement de votre écran
par rapport aux besoins de l'application
derrière donc si vous avez une
application qui nécessitent du sang vers
ce notamment certains jeux certaines
applications bien vous serez sûr sont
ouvertes mais si par contre vous êtes en
train de naviguer sur votre smartphone
classiquement et vous avez besoin de 60
hertz uniquement et bien vous allez
switcher en 60 hertz ça c'est ce que
vous êtes sur les samsung galaxy s 21 et
que vous n'avez pas ici si vous
choisissez 120 hertz vous resterez sur
120 hertz tout le temps la même chose
pour 90 verges ce qui va avoir pour
effet de venir consommer davantage au
niveau de votre batterie puisque vous
serez tout le temps en 90 m et on
s'emmerde voilà il faut savoir pour moi
je veux qu'on redéfinisse un petit peu
cette gamme parce que cette gamelle et
complexes on m'a comparé effectivement
sur la photo et la vidéo et la gamme s
on passe sur le meilleur rapport qualité
prix avec le s20 à feu ensuite on arrive
sur l'a72 à 72 à 52 5 g à 52 4 g il y en
a un peu pour toutes les bourses et au
dessous
qu'est ce qui se passe en dessous tu
m'as donné des référents tout à l'heure
on peut expliquer à quoi elle correspond
la gamme au contraire elle est une très
claire aujourd'hui hp samsung parce que
vous avez les les galaxy a qui sont
vraiment les produits sous 500 euros à
dire l'entrée dans la famille galaxy est
au dessus les galaxy s qui sont nos
produits porte étendard qui embarque les
dernières innovations et je ne parle pas
des galaxy z qui sont les smartphones
pliable qu'on va mettre un peu de côté
aujourd'hui pour autant sur les galaxies
à c'est très simple à suivre
vous avez des produits qui partent donc
du galaxy à 0,2 s jusqu'au galaxie à 60
2 plus vous montez dans ce nombre
meyer et le produit
donc aujourd'hui séparé la gamme en 3 on
va dire on a un galaxy s à 0 2 aces et
un galaxy à 12 qui sont sous les 200
euros avec un écran lcd avec un lecteur
d'empreintes sur le côté avec un triple
capteur photo qui vont proposer ce que
c'est ce que sait faire samsung sous les
200 euros donc un excellent rapport
qualité prix mais avec un écran lcd
notamment au dessus vous avez lea 32 4g
est à 32 5 g qui ouvre un peu plus loin
parce que l'offre photo et mieux fournis
par ce qu'on va passer sur du super
amoled notamment sur sur le à 32 et ce
type de choses donc un produit qui monte
en gamme et quand vous allez un petit
peu plus haut sur les 52 à 72
là vous avez non seulement un écran
super amoled et une offre et photos qui
me fournit mais ben voilà tout un tas de
choses en plus comme com
la chargeant de sahwa dont j'ai parlé la
compatibilité avec le xbox game pas ce
dont on a parlé tout à l'heure à des
haut parleurs stéréo et ce type de
choses qui viennent me dire muscler la
fiche technique et qui en font la
résistance à l'eau chose qui est très
important sur ces quelque chose
d'important à mettre sur leurs 52 à 72
ch et résistance à l'eau chose qui me
manquait jusqu'à présent qui manquait je
ne sais pas en tout cas c'est une
demande c'est comme pardon le fait de
proposer au moins trois ans de mise à
jour sur nova 52 aujourd'hui minimum et
quatre ans de mise à jour de sécurité
minimum
oui vraiment des caractéristiques qu'on
n'évoque pas forcément dans nos grandes
campagnes de communication mais c'est
important d'échanger ensemble là dessus
parce que voilà c'est des choses qui
montrent que le produit est fiable et
durable au quotidien
un écran qui certifie lutter contre la
lumière bleue et vous avez un capteur
d'empreintes digitales optique situé
sous l'écran que ce soit sur leur 52e ou
1,72 vous avez un appareil photo avec un
capteur principal un grand temps de 64
mégapixels avec une ouverture de f 1.8
stabilisé optiquement dans les deux cas
vous avez un ultra grand-angle de 12
mégapixels avec une ouverture de f 2.2
dans les deux cas vous allez avoir un
capteur macro de 5 mégapixels qui ouvre
à f 2.4 et sur le à 52 vous avez un
capteur portrait qui est là pour le mode
portrait cas pour les faits évoqués de 5
mégapixels couvre f 2.4 et qui
remplaçait sur le à 72 par un
téléobjectif avec 15 nautiques faudra
donc si vous voulez venir zoomer dans
l'image et c'est pour vous le fait
d'avoir un zoom optique c'est important
à 72 si vous vous en fichez vous gagnez
sur le prix et vous avez semblé 52 on va
retrouver notre single take on a un mode
photo de nuit également vous pouvez
filmer chez en 4k à 30 images par
seconde et dans les deux cas vous avez
une caméra telle fille de 30 2
mégapixels chouette lancement fois de
lancement
ouais maintenant alors on en aurait
préféré parce que là on t'accueille chez
nous dans nos locaux on est très bien
j'aime tous les rites d'accueillir dans
un endroit ouvert au public
en ces temps actuels mais bon déjà très
content de pouvoir échanger sur sur ses
produits et de pouvoir les proposer sur
le marché français c'est des super
produit notamment le à 52,5 j'ai un
excellent rapport qualité prix dans la
famille de chez samsung galaxy est en
tout cas on est persuadé que
qui sera très intéressant sur la chaîne
et que les gens vont te poser tout un
tas de questions dessus quelques une
marque elle regarde les commentaires
sous des vidéos en garde vous regarde et
on leur donne des garanties pas de lire
tous les commandes héros mais tu vois
tes vidéos typiquement dans la
discussion qu'on avait à l'instant tu me
dis nous ont fait des études sur des
panels
mais est ce que tu dis aussi que les
commentaires que tu peux avoir sur des
feedbacks et notamment sur différents
médias que ce soit du du média en ligne
que ce soit de la vidéo c'est des choses
que vous regardez ça ça vous intéresse
aussi maintenant c'est des choses qu'on
regarde je prends alors je sortir un peu
de l'univers youtube mais les tests que
font tes confrères de la presse écrite
des cieux non mais c'est aussi le cas
pour les vidéos youtube on va remonter
on va regarder ce qui est écrit les
points qu'on peut améliorer sur nos
produits
le whisky avec l'italie sa soeur haute
aux journalistes oui autre grand public
sait ce qu'est ce que c'est un jeu
intéressant aussi pour moi c'est hyper
intéressant façon c'est quelque chose
chez samsung qu'on fait depuis
maintenant plus de dix ans adapté de pro
nos produits sont les retours
consommateurs un des exemples ces
interfaces oignies ouailles on sait que
ça avait été critiqué à l'époque il ya
quatre ou cinq ans dans notre interface
été critiqué parce qu'ils étaient peut
être assez lourde et c'est pas forcément
la plus la plus simple à appréhender et
aujourd'hui ça s'est largement améliorée
grâce à tous et toutes ses remontées et
on est hyper fière de proposer une
interface aussi aboutis donc on écoute
les retours des consommateurs en les re
monte on écoute t retour aussi les
retours de tes confrères et après on
essaie en tout cas de
de faire en sorte qu'il soit appliqué le
mieux possible de produits sur le galaxy
à 52 vous avez une grosse batterie de
4500 milliampères heures tandis que sur
l'a72 vous êtes à 5000 millan paire eur
on peut avoir une charge rapide qui va
jusqu'à 25 watts il faut savoir qu'à
l'intérieur de votre boîte vous ont bien
chargeant de 15 mois inclus vous avez
déjà un bloc de charges en plus ce qui
est déjà bien et si vous voulez aller
plus loin si vous voulez recharger plus
vite et bien il faudra sortir l'argent
pour acheter un chargeur de 25 watts
m'en rester tranquille je pense que le
15 watts comme ça déjà fera la faire il
faut juste vous organiser pour prévoir
le temps de charge donc dans l'idée
c'est largement suffisant sur les
modèles 4g c'est à dire lui à 52 4 g et
le à 72 4 g vous avez un dragon 720
tandis que sur le à 52 5 g vous avez un
sens dragonne 750 donc on aura un peu
plus de performances dans tous les cas
vous avez ainsi giga de ram et 128 go de
stockage extensible grâce à une carte
microsd
plutôt sympa on tourne bien évidemment
sur unibail trois points d'ailleurs j'en
ai parlé de wang wei trois points en jeu
les faits une vidéo d'astuces doivent
est à venir la découvrir
et tout ça bien évidemment basé sur
android 11 voulait aussi en profiter
pour remercier toutes les personnes qui
qui nous font confiance aujourd'hui sur
cette gamme de produits parce que c'est
quelque chose qui est très important
pour nous et c'est pour ça aussi qu'on
est très fier et très content de pouvoir
proposer un galaxy à 52 5 g qui est
aussi bien fourni pour un produit sous
les moins de 500 euros il vous avez une
offre de lancement s'il vous intéresse
vous avez des galaxies petit plus qui
sont offerts jusqu'au 7 avril pour tout
achat d'un de ses modèles d'ailleurs si
vous intéresse vous aimez le lien en bas
dans la description d'ailleurs dit moi
vous ce que vous en pensez par rapport à
tout ça en bas en commentaire lequel
vous préférez à 52 4 g 5 g à 72 4 g il
ya plein d'autres modèles qui sont
sortis également il ya lui à 42 dont je
vous ai parlé il ya quelques temps après
on parlera également d'autres modèles
aux paras du à 32 dans les temps à venir
et je voudrais bien évidemment pour
savoir quel smartphone samsung ht en
2021 parce qu'on voit la gamme
hélas la gamme est large elle va
continuer à s'élargir avec d'autres
produits qui devraient arriver bien
évidemment la gamme d'offres qui
arrivera cet été juillet août
et puis des modèles qui arrive
régulièrement peut-être d'autres pliable
allez savoir vous avez donc à dire ce
que vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
on se retrouve très vite pour continuer
bien évidemment à parler de teck parler
de samsung et de tous les autres
des gros bisous beaucoup d'amour sans
voix des coeurs puis moi je me fais un
petit parti parce que là les jeux sympa
à faire